thank God each phase of life brings more
information about life and you get old
enough to have a significant number of
contemporaries who have died it's
different from theoretically thinking
about having contemporaries who have
died and your relation to your parents
changes as you pass ages that you can
remember the mat quite well I say thank
God because for the artist you want
things the sense of change in a sense of
discovery and getting older so far has a
series of discoveries to it your
relation to time is different maybe I
could have said 15 or 20 years ago the
time doesn't only fly it accelerates now
I really know that accelerates if I
think I read something in the magazine a
few weeks ago it's probably a few months
ago if I think I saw someone or did
something a year ago it was probably
three years ago because my old sense of
time is subject to this acceleration and
that's interesting but little panic
making is there's also something
exciting about it and interesting about
it and you're constantly getting used to
the idea that people are 20 who you
think of as 12 people are not who you
think of as three and indeed people are
80 and 75 when you think of is 50 and 40
and that's interesting
it's a great question why time
accelerates as you get older I suppose
because the reality at the end becomes
practically closer I don't know if that
explains it completely but I believe I'm
not alone in this perception it's like
some physical process it's like when the
hourglass is going to sand seems to go
very quickly at the very end and the
water out of the bathtub it's something
like that
you